I mean sure if I was not being a shady
piece of [ __ ] but do you think that
that's likely no no III mean I times I
haven't cheated but it's like you're
texting not texting thing you take it is
difficult it's difficult to not text
yeah it's hard to not text no thumbs up
today yeah it's the first time then why
cuz Jim said thank you Oh our intern AJ
always gives Jim a thumbs up when he
drops off his breakfast cuz I would do
that I used to do that like Rogers
thumbs up face thank you to somebody but
so you couldn't hear it on the air I
feel like you did it once on his first
day and then every day after that he
started giving you a thumbs up well he
wants to you know think you know it's
just too much and to what degree is
other stuff suffering tension going on
between them all the time
tension going on between them all the
time what you thinking about okay you
sure
okay I'm curious but we'll get there I
was just a dumb kid going like this is
what I'm doing I told everybody I could
not believe they were able to follow
that show right yeah I think that it was
definitely
[Music]
it's googled it
yeah she uh you know it's it's okay
using the company and the company but
then when he came in without doing the
thumbs up today well I just said the
analyzer said thank you
normally wouldn't into the mic it's
distracting it's unprofessional exciting
nice distressful when you get that thumb
in your face every day he's a good boy